I think the only thing everybody was  doing today was watching the Supreme  Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh and his  accuser professor Christine Blasi Ford  you know give their testimony and as I  said the hearing was emotional at times  tense it was absolutely riveting and it  was crazy because every day when  something like this happens in America  where everyone's watching literally  everyone in America was watching this  event today and I'm not exaggerating  check this out we continued our hearing  on the nomination of Judge Brent  Cavanaugh let's have a nonpartisan  professional investigation so what you  were telling us is this could not be a  case of mistaken my brain absolutely not  [Music]  process  [Music]  [Music]  you  you